this guy who was trying to cure
homelessness he wrote a book called san
francisco
he's like homelessness is yeah and and
he was like how do progressives ruin
america's cities part of it is just
basically saying well they're victims
and there should be no consequences for
their behavior so you're an addict that
doesn't work in in
the netherlands and portugal these po
these countries that have amazing drug
policies
it's not legal to shoot up but there are
consequences and there are carrots and
sticks
and you get also consequences for being
a fuck-up you can't just have no
consequences and say well you're a
victim and that was kind of the argument
but he was talking about gavin newsom
and the guy who was at the charge of all
the homeless psychiatric policies yeah
it's a it's a leadership issue he said
what do you mean he goes and the guy
goes i don't think gavin is a bad guy he
goes and rogan said really and he goes
no no i don't think that he's just not
doesn't have the intellectual software
goes away being called a bad guy yeah
right yeah
not at all because i don't want to be
mean go wrong because not being mean
you're telling the truth yeah the guy
doesn't read yeah not at all so he's and
i've uh
i
not impressive that way not not not not
a big yeah yeah yeah looks the part but
not
and and tends to toe that [ __ ] line
so um forgive me if i don't trust
what he has to say no that's fair never
have yeah wait what was this book
that you were talking about it's called
san francisco and rogan just had him on
his podcast
really really and this guy was a hard
left [ __ ] you know he worked with the
soros foundation and all that stuff and
he but but he's like look man
you you there are there are ways to
solve this problem and the way we're
doing it now is not how to solve the
problem exactly
the homeless yeah
we have probably actually a hundred and
fifty thousand right so the same friends
sicko uh progressive claim they knew how
to solve the homeless
problem inequality and crime but in
cities that control progressives made
those problems worse yeah he lived in
san fran uh for 30 years during that
time he advocated
uh the criminalization of drugs
alternative jail to prison so he's a
left-wing guy this is a left-wing guy
taking his own group to task for the
fact that they they just are and by the
way and so apparently george soros is to
blame partially because he funds the
most left far left progressives i don't
know what it is but the [ __ ] um you
know san francisco city council l.a city
council
they don't even really have democrats on
there they these are socialists and
far-left radicals far left radicals like
i'm talking about marxists and stuff so
what do they what do they want to be
done with well the idea would be the
idea would be
homelessness the long narrative was
homelessness was a housing shortage well
this guy's been studying it i mean in
the trenches for 20 years he goes i've
never seen that it's all drugs and it's
all mental illness it's schizophrenia
and it's drugs
when are we going to come to terms with
that and there are ways like other
countries have done really well at
dealing with it they just create that
like if you're caught doing drugs so in
holland if you're caught shooting up
well they'll take you to jail now what
happens is you show up and there's a
prosecutor there are police there's also
your family there's also a counselor a
caseworker and i assume when they go to
prison in those areas they're not
getting because
you're prison is more
there it's just more drug dealing more
yeah yeah
and scattered yeah yeah here we house
our crazies and unfortunately a lot of
people have mental illness not their
fault man you have people on the street
who have schizophrenia yeah and you can
keep a one an old lady with dementia uh
under house arrest essentially or you
know but the aclu the american civil
liberties union which i which i which i
support for the most part they they're
like you can't wear an ankle bracelet if
you're a drug addict that's that's a
violation there are civil liberties and
if somebody's a schizophrenic you're not
allowed to house them you're not allowed
to essentially take them off the street
because they're just the best their best
is just to leave them on the street
yeah they're afraid that the state will
start running state-run hospitals it'll
be one flew over the cuckoo's nest but
again this is the americans have trouble
being good luck solving it yeah that's a
[ __ ] well he said so he said and
rogan he were talking about something
really interesting they were like the
problem is that we're politically
homeless guys like you and me we're all
political yeah i don't have a team
i can't join with the republicans
because they're they're they're not
pro-choice they don't want to legalize
drugs they got a lot of issues you know
i i can't go with the progressives
because they want to decriminalize the
border and they're [ __ ] crazy
so where do i go if i'm if i'm socially
liberal fiscally conservative
unreasonable yeah and that rogers we
need a new year
so we should lock you up me yeah where
wherever you want be nice